your iPhone can be hacked even when it's
turned off according to researchers in
Germany certain iPhone components such
as Bluetooth NFC and uwb chips remain
active even when the phone is off
Packers can exploit this loophole by
manipulating the iOS firmware and
installing malicious software the
researchers claim that this cannot be
fixed through an iOS update and that the
problem affects iPhone's 11 through 14.
the researchers informed Apple but the
company still hasn't responded so what
can you do to protect your iPhone from
hackers at the moment disabling the send
last location option in find my iPhone
seems to be the only thing you can do
however keep in mind that if you turn
off the semlast location option your
iPhone won't be able to broadcast its
most recent location
[Music]
thank you